>>> RIGHT NOW RESEARCHERS ARE
WORKING TO LEARN MORE ABOUT UN'
EARTHED DEBRIS BELIEVED TO BE
THE REMNANTS FROM A SHIPWRECK
DISCOVERED IN FLORIDA CAUSED BY
COASTAL EROSION BY HURRICANE IAN
AND NICOLE EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THE OBJECT WAS PREVIOUSLY BURIED
UNDER FIVE FEET OF SAND ALONG
FLORIDA'S ATLANTIC COAST EAST OF
ORLANDO.
THEY ARE WORKING WITH STATE
OFFICIALS IN FLORIDA TO STUDY
WHAT THEY THINK MIGHT BE A
WRECK.
HI, CHUCK, FIRST OF ALL.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
I'M WONDERING --
>> I'M DOING GREAT.
>> WONDERFUL.
WHAT ABOUT THAT DEBRIS OR DEBRIS
FIELD MAKES YOU THINK THAT
POSSIBLY IT IS A SHIP?
>> WELL, THANKS SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME.
WE WERE ASKED BY THE STATE OF
FLORIDA, MY INSTITUTION,S WHICH
IS BASED OUT OF THE ST.
AUGUSTINE LIGHTHOUSE AND
MARITIME MUSEUM TO GO OUT AND
LOOK AT THE SPACE DEBRIS.
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT MIGHT BE THE
BLEACHERS FROM WHEN THEY DID
RACES AT DAYTONA.
WE CAN SEE DEFINITIVELY IT IS A
SHIPWRECK.
WE CAN SEE CEILING PLANKING,
FRAMES, STRINGERS WITH
PARTICULARLY SCARVES AND THE
FASTENERS USED TO HOLD THE
TIMBERS TOGETHER.
IT IS DEFINITELY A SAILING --
THE REMAINS OF A SAILING SHIP,
AND ALMOST CERTAINLY DATES TO
THE 1800s.
>> OH, MY GOSH, FASCINAFASCINAT.
WHAT ABOUT 9 MARKERS OR PIECES
OF THE SHIP CERTAINLY MAKE YOU
BELIEVE IT IS FROM THE 1800s?
CAN YOU GIVE ME AN IDEA OF SOME
OF THE DETAILS THAT WERE
UNEARTHED?
>> YEAH.
IT'S INTERESTING.
IF YOU HAVE A RANDOM PIECE OF
WOODEN HULL TIMBERS THAT COME UP
ON THE BEACH, MOST STATISTICALLY
ALONE THEY WILL DATE TO THE
1800s.
THAT'S BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MUCH
MORE SHIPPING IN THE 19th
CENTURIES, OR THE 1800s, THAN WE
DID IN PREVIOUS CENTURIES.
WE START OFF ALMOST WITH THAT
ASSUMPTION.
THEN WE ARE LOOKING AT AS BEST
WE CAN.
IN THIS CASE WHAT HAD BEEN
EXPOSED WAS BURIED AGAIN.
WE HAD TO DIG DOWN TO EXPOSE THE
TIMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
LOOKING CLOSELY AT THE TIMBERS,
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING THAT
WOULD SUGGEST AN EARLIER DATE
FOR MORE RECENT DATE.
IT IS CONSIST WITH THE BOLTS OR
IRON SPIKES OR WOODEN PEGS THAT
ARE HOLDING THE TIMBERS
TOGETHER.
EVERYTHING IS CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN ON OTHER SHIP
WRECKS THAT DATE TO THE 1800s.
>> WOW.
DO YOU HAVE ANY SUSPICION OR ARE
YOU FAMILIAR WITH ANY SHIPS,
NAMES OF SHIPS OR THE USE OF THE
SHIPS FROM THE 1800s THAT THIS
COULD BE PART OF?
I REMEMBER DIVING WITH A DIVE
GROUP THAT WERE LOOKING FOR
SLAVE TRADE SHIPS ALONG THE
FLORIDA COAST.
>> IT'S MOST LIKELY THAT THIS IS
A MERCHANT VESSEL.
THESE BIG WOODEN SAILING
SHIPS -- YOU KNOW, AMERICA WAS A
MARITIME NATION.
WE BUILT OUR POWER BECAUSE OF
THE PROXIMITY TO THE OCEANS ON
EITHER SIDE OF OUR NATION.
THIS WOULD BE THE EQUIVALENT OF
AN 18-WHEELER WE SEE ON THE
INTERSTATE TODAY.
IT'S PROBABLY NOT LIKELY THAT IT
DATES TO THE SLAVE TRADE.
PROBABLY AFTER THE LIVE TRADE
WAS OUTLAWED.
IT SEEMS, AGAIN, WE'RE -- ODDS
ARE CERTAINLY THAT IT WAS
CARRYING A CARGO, PERHAPS CARGO
OF LUMBER.
IF IT WAS COMING FROM THE
CARIBBEAN, SAILING NORTH IT
COULD HAVE HAD A CARGO OF FRUIT.
IF IT WAS COMING FROM THE GULF
OF MEXICO, SAILING ALONG THE
FLORIDA COAST, IT COULD HAVE HAD
CARGO OF LUMBER.
FROM BOSTON, NEW YORK, IT MAY
HAVE HAD MANUFACTURED GOODS.
IT'S MOST LIKELY ONE OF THESE,
AGAIN, KIND OF 18-WHEELERS OF
THE 19th CENTURY, BRINGING GOODS
TO OR FROM ONE PART OF OUR COAST
TO ANOTHER.
>> OKAY.
AND THEN WHAT WILL YOU DO WITH
THE REMNANTS OF THIS FIND?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
A LOT OF FOLKS ASK IF WE WILL BE
DIGGING UP THE ENTIRE SHIPWRECK
AND PUTTING IT ON DISPLAY.
IT'S JUST PROHIBITIVELY
EXPENSIVE TO TRY TO RECOVER
WATERLOGGED TIMBERS THAT ARE A
FEW HUNDRED YEARS OLD THAT IN
THIS CASE MAY BE 80 TO 100 FEET
LONG IS WHAT PEOPLE RECORDED THE
SIZE OF THE WRECK FROM WHAT THEY
SAW WHEN IT WAS MORE FULLY
EXPOSED.
IT WOULD TAKE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS LITERALLY TO PRESERVE
THE TIMBERS.
NOW, IF THEY STAY WHERE THEY
ARE, IF THEY'RE BURIED, IN THE
DARK, THEY WILL LAST HUNDREDS
AND HUNDREDS MORE YEARS.
IF WE ARE TO PULL THE TIMBERS
OUT, THEY WOULD BEGIN TO DRY
OUT.
UNLESS WE ACTED FAST AND GOT
THEM SUB MERGE INDEED A VAT OF
CHEMICALS, WE WOULD HAVE TO HEAT
THE CHEMICALS.
YOU HAVE TO DO THAT TO PRESERVE
THE WOOD.
IT IS REALLY SOMETHING THAT IS
SO EXPENSIVE, THE BEST THING FOR
US TO DO TO PROTECT THE SHIP IS
TO RECORD IT.
WE HAVE TAKEN WOOD SAMPLES,
MEASUREMENTS, A LOT OF
PHOTOGRAPHS.
WE CAN GENERATE A 3D MODEL.
SO WE HAVE RECORDED IT AS BEST
WE CAN TO TRY TO HOPEFULLY
UNDERSTAND IT AND MAYBE WHEN WE
DO SOME RESEARCH IN THE
HISTORICAL ARCHIVES, IDENTIFY IT
PERHAPS BY NAME.
>> INCREDIBLE.
>> WE HAVE CANDIDATES THAT WENT
DOWN IN THE AREA.
BUT IT IS -- THERE'S NO WAY WE
CAN TAKE THE ENTIRE SHIP OUT.
>> CHU